c'est l'un des effets collatéraux des
annonces des manuels macron depuis
l'élargissement du pass sanitaire la
bande de documents trafic et explose sur
internet il suffit de quelques minutes
sur les réseaux sociaux pour trouver des
dizaines de revendeurs des comptes
anonymes en forme de petites annonces
avec un argument de vente et prix
affichés entre 100 et 300 euros pour
éviter le vaccin
les faussaires vous promettre un
certificat de vaccination en 48 heures
téléchargeable sur le site de
l'assurance maladie
mais ces transactions sont en fait des
arnaques
car selon ce spécialiste il est
quasiment impossible de créer un faux qr
code
l'intérêt du pass numérique c'est qu'on
a une signature cryptographique donc il
va être beaucoup plus difficile à
falsifier qu'un pass papier pour faire
simple c'est un calcul qui va être fait
à partir des données dans le pass
sanitaire donc votre identité et les
données sanitaires
et puis avec une clé secrète que seules
les autorités de santé possède si ces
protections informatiques sont
difficiles à contourner les
manipulations illégal viennent parfois
de personnes travaillant au sein même du
système de santé
pour en savoir plus nous prenons contact
avec un faussaire en nous faisant passer
pour une cliente intéressés qu'est ce
que c'est que ce qu il ya donc toi tu
travailles avec des médecins en fait
c'est ça ta l'intermédiaire est âpre est
des gens qui
se connecte sur le site de l'assurance
maladie
[Rires]
comme ses complices profitent de leur
accès à la base de données de
l'assurance maladie à des fins
lucratives
ce pharmacien par exemple comme ses
confrères peut intervenir sur le dossier
d'un patient en rentrant simplement son
numéro de sécurité sociale donc on me
demande si j'ai l'autorisation d'accéder
aux patients coop
je dis oui et là donc je suis sur le
dossier on voit le statut si je veux je
peux le reprendre je peux annuler le
cycle et en refaire
c'est assez simple faire quelque chose
de fraude yeux évidemment on peut même
déclaré des effets d'un dédia vous voyez
donc on va très loin dans la dans
l'outil qui a été mis en place
imprimé l'attestation certifié là c'est
ça c'est le fameux graal un graal
parfois obtenu au prix d'une trahison du
serment d'hippocrate et qui pourrait
ternir l'image de toute une profession
c'est ça qui sèment le doute parce
qu'aujourd'hui on entend plein
d'informations et quand un soignant lui
dinan j'y crois pas où ça sert à rien
vous imagine que tout le travail qui est
fait par les autres professionnels de
santé qui sont droits dans leurs bottes
qui utilisent les études scientifiques
pour avancer des arguments
ça fout tout le travail en l'air et ça
décrédibilise tout donc non ça doit être
puni c'est c'est inconcevable si ces
comportements restent minoritaires ne
sont pas rares pour autant récemment
plusieurs fraudeurs dont une
pharmacienne ont été mis en examen dans
une enquête portant sur un trafic de
faux certificats de vaccination pour
l'argent ou par conviction
certains professionnels de santé à
inité avec tin et propose également de
simuler purement l'injection
l'un d'entre eux a accepté de témoigner
anonymement
il dit avoir commencé gratuitement il ya
deux mois pour rendre service à des amis
[Musique]
que le combat aujourd'hui pour un faux
pas et vous connaissez d'autres
personnes qui pensent à vous avez des
collègues faire la même chose que vous
lorsque nous évoquons les risques qu'ils
encourent
les conséquences ne semble pas
l'inquiéter
comment lutter contre ce nouveau trafic
le projet de loi étendant le pass and i
ter prévoit des contrôles réalisés par
les forces de l'ordre
problème elles ne sont pas toutes
équipées de téléphone permettant de lire
les qr codes pour les syndicats de
policiers les moyens nécessaires au
contrôle sont bien loin de la réalité
aujourd'hui les policiers sont sur tous
les fronts et qu'ils ont quand même de
la petite et moyenne délinquance la
lutte contre le terrorisme
les contrôles aux frontières ils ont la
lutte contre les stupéfiants les
violences conjugales qui sont des
priorités ministérielles
alors si vous voulez des tournées de
missions prioritaires sur du contrôle
sanitaire et bien dans ce cas là il faut
qu'ils aient un arbitrage politique s'il
est difficile d'évaluer l'ampleur du
trafic
les fraudeurs et utilisateurs de fausses
attestations de vaccination en cours de
vrais risques pour faux et usage de faux
la loi française prévoit jusqu'à trois
ans de prison et 45000 euros d'amendé
[Applaudissements]